being moved out of your normal frame
gives you some freedom somehow that
makes you think in new ways and do crazy
things which is good which is a good
reason to move is that it actually
shakes you up a bit
allows you to do other things you can
redefine yourself when you move that's
exactly what ullis kerning Matteson did
she's an architect interior designer and
now a cafe owner in 2012 she and her
family moved from the Danish capital
Copenhagen to Berlin the new city a new
project a special cafe in her search for
a suitable location
she found a former antique shop she and
her husband spent more than two months
renovating it they designed and built
the furnishings themselves as an
interior designer olace kerning Madison
has already decorated many boutiques and
cafés her own Cafe East and Eden is
seventy square meters in size
the eastern eden name comes from the
book of by john steinbeck east of eden
and we had a list of names and one of
them that we really liked was this East
of Eden because it contained the word
East East Berlin and Eden as the nice
place we wanted to make so we decided to
twist it a little bit and call it East
and Eden Poulos coning Madison was born
in 1967 in a small town near Copenhagen
she grew up with two siblings after
leaving school she studied architecture
and lived in Italy Australia and New
Zealand in the East and even cafe hula
offers a small selection of food dishes
that are easy and uncomplicated to
prepare she says that's typically Danish
as a teenager she did an internship in a
cake shop and developed a passion for
the trade she makes all the sweet treats
herself according to her own recipes
I'm lucky enough to have a dentist for a
mother and growing up in the seventies
in in Denmark it meant that we were not
allowed to eat candy sugar on weekdays
we could have it on Saturdays my mother
really wanted to encourage us to to make
food and whatever so I I realized that
it was okay for me to bake a cake and
that was sugar so every day I would come
home from school and I would bake
something and there's always been a big
hobby of mine and there's something I've
always been been doing Danes are said to
have a sweet tooth oat biscuits with
licorice are both popular and simple to
make they take only about three-quarters
of an hour including the baking time
they can easily be combined with
different ingredients for example with
cranberries these give the biscuits a
fruity taste Denmark is known for good
licorice it's not only eaten as a candy
but also used as a spice licorice is
extracted from the root of the licorice
plant which grows mainly in the
Mediterranean region nowadays many top
restaurants also use licorice as a
seasoning using liquorice all the cuts
in recipe for me is like using a new
spice it's not even thinking about the
cuts when I'm using it it's like using
cinnamon or Muscat or any other spice it
gives it this really nice deep warm
flavor before Ulla and her family moved
to Berlin she searched for a suitable
school for her daughter founded in the
mitr district
here she immediately felt at home
she likes the colorful mix of people who
live here
miss is a very international place to be
we can also see it as our customers here
in the cafe they come from all over the
world good places to eat nice places to
go for our coffees and good shopping
nice supermarkets does everything you
really need here so we never use a car
in Berlin we're always on our bikes
because everything is close by so it's a
it's a nice little city in the city
initially olace kerning Matteson only
opened her cafe five days of the week
but her concept has been so well
received that it's now open every day it
ate her back how I can scare me like
this at Hannover will come